أهمية الحوسبة الكمومية مبالَغ في التقليل منها
والمبالغة في تضخيمها في الوقت ذاته.
رغم أنها لن تحل محل الحواسيب التقليدية
فإن الابتكار الكمومي يمثل نموذجًا حوسبيًا جديدًا.
يمكن للحواسيب الكمومية أن تعمل جنبًا إلى جنب مع الحوسبة الحالية
والبنية التحتية لحل مشاكل معقدة كانت سابقًا
تُعدّ غير عملية أو مستحيلة.
هذا قد يغير قواعد اللعبة كليًا.
مثلًا، صعوبة تحليل الأعداد الكبيرة
إلى عواملها الأولية هي أساس
التشفير الحديث. بالنسبة لحجم الأرقام المستخدمة في المفتاح العام
الخاص الحديث، ستستغرق هذه العملية الحسابية
أسرع حاسوب تقليدي أكثر من 300 تريليون سنة.
بالنسبة لحاسوب كمومي واسع النطاق يعمل
بخوارزمية Shor، قد تستغرق هذه العملية ثوانٍ.
مشاكل معقدة كهذه موجودة في كل الصناعات.
التطبيقات المحتملة للحوسبة الكمومية
واسعة جدًا.
الحواسيب الكمومية تكبر بالفعل
وتصبح أكثر قدرة،
ونحن نسعى لمعالجة مشاكل أكثر تعقيدًا.
منذ عام 2016، أتاحت IBM الحواسيب الكمومية
للعامة عبر موقع إلكتروني بواجهة رسومية تشبه
الورقة الموسيقية.
وعبر مجموعة أدوات تطوير البرمجيات Qiskit
التي تتيح للمستخدمين برمجة الحواسيب الكمومية.
علماء داخل وخارج عالم الشركات
يجرون تجارب
عبر بوابات مماثلة. يستكشفون مناهج في الكيمياء
ومشاكل تعلم الآلة، محاولين معرفة
أنواع الأسئلة التي يمكنهم طرحها
وكيف سيصيغون تلك الأسئلة
حين تتطور التكنولوجيا أكثر. الآن هو
الوقت المناسب لقادة الأعمال للاستعداد
للكم. الظروف متهيئة للتجريب
وتوسيع هذه التكنولوجيا الجديدة جوهريًا.
المؤسسات التي تسعى لتكون في
طليعة هذا التحول الجذري ستنتزع
الميزة التنافسية. هذا التدريب
سيهيئك لبدء رحلتك الكمومية!